PRIYANKA VERGADIA: With almost
500 sessions at Next 2019,
it's understandable that you
couldn't get to all of them.
So if you didn't see Cloud
Data Fusion, Data Integration
at Google Cloud,
then stay tuned,
because here's the rewind.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
The biggest barrier to
enterprise data analysis
and machine learning
is data integration.
It is not uncommon to
see companies struggle
to get their data in one place,
move it around, transform
it, and make sense out of it.
Because honestly, it's a
really hard problem to solve.
Cloud Data Fusion is a
fully-managed, cloud-native
data integration service that
helps users efficiently build
and manage data pipelines.
With a graphical interface and
a broad open sourced library
of preconfigured connectors
and transformations,
Data Fusion shifts an
organization's focus
away from code and integration
to insights and action.
Data Fusion is built on the
open-source project CDAP.
And this open core ensures data
pipeline portability for users.
Data Fusion aims at making the
lives of data practitioners
easier by providing a graphical
user interface to visually
drag and drop elements
to create data pipelines,
and then finally run it on GCP.
In Data Fusion, we collect
metadata information
on fields and tables, and
expose them as lineage,
so you can do root cause
analysis and impact analysis.
Data Fusion can solve
a variety of use cases.
If you're building a data
warehouse using BigQuery,
you should look at
Data Fusion, since it
can connect to multiple
different data sources,
like Oracle and other relational
and non-relational databases.
If you're looking to
retire a legacy system,
Data Fusion can help you
migrate the data to GCP.
If you're looking
to consolidate data,
or in a hybrid
environment, you can
use Data Fusion for
data consistency
across cloud and
on-premise environment.
Data Fusion natively
integrates with Google Cloud,
which simplifies data
security and ensures
your data is immediately
available for analysis.
Data Fusion offers both
preconfigured transformations
from an OSS library
as well as the ability
to create an internal
library of custom connections
and transformations that can be
validated, shared, and reused
across an organization.
It lays the foundation of
collaborative data engineering
and improves productivity.
This means less waiting for
data engineers, and importantly,
less sweating
about code quality.
If you would like to see
the full talk and the demo,
check out the link in
the description below.
And don't forget to subscribe
to the Cloud YouTube
channel for more great
Next Rewind content.
Thank you for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]